even John Breck it evening to you and
just moments ago the Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo issued a tweet saying
looking forward to meeting with kim
yeongcheol in New York to discuss
president Trump's potential summit with
chairman Kim we are committed to the
complete verifiable and irreversible
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
around here at the White House that keep
using the word potential to describe the
summit but they are proceeding as if it
is in place for June the 12th president
Trump met with Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo today a strategy session ahead of
pompei OHS meetings in New York with
North Korean vice chairman kim
yeongcheol a prelude to president trumps
possible summit with kim jong-un we're
continuing to prepare for the meeting
between the president in the North
Korean leader as the president says if
it happens we'll certainly be ready the
White House says both its teams
dispatched his Singapore and the DMZ
over the weekend have been engaging with
North Korean delegations the advance
team led by deputy chief of staff Jo
Hagen met with the North Korean team in
Singapore earlier today the u.s.
delegation led by ambassador Sung Kim
met with North Korean officials earlier
today as well and their talks will
continue so far the readout from these
meetings has been positive
as he toured events at his presidential
sport and fitness event today the
president contrasted the improving
relations with North Korea by taking
another swing at his Attorney General
Jeff Sessions after congressman trey
Gowdy said this morning he understands
the president's frustration that
sessions recused himself in the Russia
investigation if I were the president
and I picked someone to be the country's
chief law enforcement officer and they
told me later oh by the way I'm not
going to be able to participate in the
most important case in the office I
would be frustrated too that's how I
read that is senator sessions why didn't
you tell me this before I picked you
there are lots of really good lawyers in
the country he could have picked someone
else the president tweeted gaudi's
entire quote about picking someone else
for attorney general adding in his own
words and I wish I did the New York
Times today reported that Special
Counsel Robert Muller is looking into a
March 2017 meeting President Trump had
with sessions at mar-a-lago a meeting at
which he reportedly asked sessions to
reverse his recusal sources familiar
with the investigation tell FOX News
Muller never spoke about that meeting to
the president's attorneys but in his
list of questions for the president
Muller was clearly interested in the
issue asking what did you think and what
did you do regarding AG sessions recusal
and what efforts did you make to try to
get him to change his mind and reverse
well the president was in lockstep with
Gowdy over sessions he was at odds with
the congressman Oberg Audi's assertion
that the FBI did nothing wrong
to get close to several members of the
president's campaign I am even more
convinced that the FBI did exactly what
my fellow citizens would want them to do
when they got the information they got
and that it has nothing to do with
Donald Trump press secretary today said
not so fast president still has concerns
about whether or not the FBI acted
inappropriately having people in his
campaign and certainly the president has
concerns about the overall conduct of
the FBI when it comes to this process
and to prove that just about anything
can happen here at the White House
reality television star Kim Kardashian
strolled across West executive drive and
into the White House late this afternoon
she is here for discussions with Jared
Kushner on prison reform she is also
advocating for a pardon for a
great-grandmother who has been
imprisoned on a nonviolent drug charge
since 1996 also spotted at the White
House today Rudy Giuliani who told the
press that he has been conducting prep
sessions with the president evenings
this week at the White House in the
event the president does decide to sit
down with Robert Moore Brett a different
Trump Kim summit tonight John thanks